[Music]
and welcome back to off the record with
the careful boys that's not being very
careful over there sorry be careful
buddy
already we're excited to have dante
voska with us today
on this episode of hot seat unlucky for
him he's already in the hot seat i don't
even know what this is [ __ ] i've never
i've never experienced it works even
better if you don't know what it is yeah
it's uh it's basically a grill session
like we were saying earlier it's like a
glory hole right under your butt hole
right there
it gets deeper and deeper it's like a
bait bicycle that has a spike go through
the seat
yeah i know all the answers to the
questions you're gonna ask me oh you do
okay do i you should you i think you're
the only one equipped to answer them how
about that yeah that's actually very
true we basically
start off asking you some very mild
questions and then as we go
we get a little bit deeper and more
personal
are we gonna need to scrub any of this
from the internet later on it's probably
not at your discretion it's an organic
conversation we always throw it on
patreon yeah man well we'd like to start
off our uh questions with the coldest
questions on earth and bart's really
good at generating those so bart please
which
which finger do you like to pick your
nose with
that's a good pointer why that one
i i think it's a good angle on the nail
but isn't it kind of big what about this
one that's kind of big but i got a big
non filipino
filipinos filipinos
that's a good little warm-up question
what what is your favorite color
blue private cobalt blue cobalt blue
cold what the
what kind of artistic [ __ ] is that bro
cobalt blue is like a really dark kind
of like deep blue it's almost it's dark
in the navy is it like metallic
it's like midnight oh man yo what the
[ __ ] is do you like
do you like busting nuts with their eyes
open or closed that's kind of hot
yeah closer you're more like
i liked it
except for some girls want you to look
them in the eye yeah
that's too much connections yeah how do
you feel about that
it depends on the girl
lights on or lights off
she's like depends on the girl
like lights on lights on lights on yeah
like a little bit or like no like a
little bit not hell of like not floral
fluorescent you don't like the led
strips like that
i like a nice warm warm light i do like
a dimmable like
salt lamp or some [ __ ] like it almost
feels like it's like candlelight but
it's actually like just ambient light
but i'm a visual person so i want to
like i kind of want to see [ __ ] you want
some tones i like i like scenes i like
to see some things i got i got a
question i got a question okay so um
would you consider yourself to be a
child actor yes okay a grown-up chat
actor because you were like in junior
high or high school when you got your
first i was like 15 when i hooked but i
started acting when i was 10. okay so
you've been in the industry from a young
age right
and then um at the same time were you
going to public school and like so you
had that double life right
[Music]
was it weird
like when people when your friends and
everyone saw you on hook
super weird
were you treated differently at school
and everything yeah he was probably
slaying a [ __ ] right after right yeah
i kept moving that was like i was living
in cerritos
and then i would do people would see me
on tv i remember someone like saw me at
wonder years and i was like oh that's
cool
and then we moved to paramount was like
the hood yeah crushing over there too
and then i did a hook but then we got
busted shoplifting
in cerritos mall after hook as an actor
in the middle of shooting hook oh no we
got hella in trouble because you almost
destroyed the movie no we got got but
then my parents like came down as hard
as during christmas i was stealing like
isotonic gloves and [ __ ]
so while you were being like a lost boy
on hook you was little
you were a lost boy at least you had a
bad boy character in the movie right
he's kind of like then we got bus to
orange county high school the arts was
that lost out and so by the time hook
came out i was like a new kid in school
at up there so i was like kind of new i
mean but were you were you a popular kid
i was probably i met my brother so we
didn't really care too much about
popularity but we were like with each
other but then all my homies like all my
homies from paramount were like doug if
you were here
when your movie came out you would have
been just slaying
and i'm like
but i'm in lost sound orange count a
bunch of girls with birkenstocks on
right now and they're just they're just
trying to trip on like i'm wearing baggy
jeans
they would make fun of you for that no
no it was cool it was cool it would just
take like
it took a while to like kind of like you
know it's a different style different
style you went from school that's like
99
like mexican and black to like school
that was like
99 white like literally there was like
13 black kids in the whole school
we were like damn this is crazy
during your acting time i'm gonna turn
up the temperatures a little bit uh you
know there's always like
the the rival right it's always two
people always going after those roles
and one person like if will smith don't
get it jamie foxx is gonna get it vin
diesel doesn't get it the rocks gonna
get it who was the guy that was coming
up in hollywood at the same time they're
like man [ __ ] you jgl no there was a
movie just gordon we were just now
george he was like a kid the cat i would
see a lot was like john chuck john cho
was on oh really
was like around the same generation
he's young too yeah john's like we're
about the same age not me like but he
started acting young too young i mean we
both started seeing each other around
like you know you're giving the eye
he's cool as hell but we're different
you know you're so different like even
if i read like like i read for
uh kumar and
helen kumar harold kamar yeah i'm
like i remember meeting the producers
and directors like you're the first
person reading this role and i went in
there and um
but i didn't get the role like the guy
was like straight up like you can't get
this rule like in the middle of it yeah
john cho's character is like a nerdy
accountant
after i watched the movie it made sense
because
he fits that stereotype of that um
college asian guy right yeah right that
doesn't go and party and whatever yeah i
was always like an alternate kind of
kumar you're the kumar people said i was
joncho's doppelganger
do you see it or not yeah
no no it's not about my hot seat all
right listen you had to do a celebrity
sex scene with anybody who would it be
oh [ __ ] male or female wow of course
nick would say that
just like these options
celebrity sexy
one for each actually how about that one
three yes i can't think of celebrity
sexy i mean
who's dope about that i mean
i'm talking ready to r we didn't talk
about that
we talking real stuff you know what i'm
saying
yeah yeah it's a french movie
it's like brown bunny or some [ __ ]
have you ever done a sex scene nope
not with the cameras
three sex scenes
like set like i've done makeout team but
like sex scenes where you're like you
have to like take it take your dick
those ones yeah like they either put
like a sock on your dick or like a sock
wait you actually did a sex scene like
that like a few two seconds two sections
why do they put a sock there so you
won't get two so you you know i don't
know just keep it is it was it what the
girl requests
well it happened one time i mean i can't
talk because she got crazy but so
uh that's the next question
i don't know about it it's getting high
i don't i mean it's first of all it's
not that sexy to do sex scenes that's
yeah
uh like and you're trying to get into it
yeah and the camera was like right
trying to be all sexy and stuff boom mic
just hitting your [ __ ] and stuff you
feel the breath of the dp camera guy
then you start thinking like oh you're
dead if i put this woman's nipple in my
mouth am i acting
oh you're you're yeah the line it's like
right or they just want to see just do
this like the director be like do this
and you're like okay i'm just gonna do
what he's telling me to do i'm sorry
it's not for pleasure wait you gotta
answer my question oh who yeah who um
right now
i don't know i mean
i really i remember like what like a few
years ago like shameless the group of
champions that girl
emmy rossum emmy
she's a great actress yeah and she did
some like naked scenes and i don't know
what the [ __ ] that here one one white
chick one asian chick one black chick
and one latin chicken oh yeah yeah
who the [ __ ] emily rossum is
we want some relatable entertainment
from this [ __ ] man yeah it's very nice
four celebrities white chick okay white
chick first
get them out the way
i don't know see i'm trying to say who's
there's so many hot ones i know some
problems but you also want to not say
someone you've met because then you used
to look like perfect okay okay is it
easier if it's not if it's not he also
knows all of these things
well let's say like now right now let's
see like oh
i don't even know la land chick i
wouldn't yeah latin chick
like i don't know i don't even know
names i don't know names on some of
these cats
oh eva longoria
like i just said
in the heyday sell my hike sell my house
okay i'm gonna suggest that she's like
spanish huh three more chips now okay
three more chips
sophia vergara i love sofia she's very
good now you already maximized the
latino okay white girl um let's go with
we can go all errors huh let me see
all errors
preferably somebody that's like you've
already wife probably someone you've
already met
someone we can add
we can tag in this video because
we can put your face next to their
strange you know not just
when you've like as a kid girl you've
like jerked off to some girl yeah
actress or something model and then you
you work with them
and they like started talking weird
[ __ ] i dropped off
i already know what you're talking about
and you're like what the [ __ ] are we
talking right now for who'd you jerk off
to is this where is this this is on
youtube it's just going to my hard drive
that is cool this classic the camera
isn't even when i was younger robin
gibbons robin gibbons
today's video is brought to you by
curology see this really cool lip balm
i've been using it like crazy it's like
a lightsaber yeah cause you could do it
one-handed so i keep mine in my uh you
know little pocket on the door and then
so when i'm driving and in vegas is
really dry i don't have to use two hands
and i can just use this and moisturize
my lips
wow look at that and you need a lot of
chapstick and dry ass places like nevada
too i have to put on i think like three
or four times a day
it's pretty dry
well i've been using curology for like
the last two years and it's pretty cool
the process is very very simple and it
takes the thinking out of all this
because you go on their site you fill
out their survey of all the things that
you need or you want a desire for your
skin you got too much grease you want to
work on that you got too many wrinkles
you want to work on that you got acne
you want to work on that well fine they
create
a licensed dermatology provider
creates a specific formula custom to you
and check it out a box comes right with
these items for me i get a face wash
right here and after that
i put my specific joe formula on and
then after that i moisturized to seal
the deal and they made all the skin care
stuff super easy for me which makes me
achieve it more when you have to think i
think that's when things get really hard
to do when i got to go to the store and
pick what is the best brand
i got to research all this ah it's too
overwhelming i don't want to do it
anymore they send this package it comes
on a routine and then i go and then i
can do my skincare routine
so if you want to up your skincare
routine go check them out because you
got a super sick deal where you get a
free 30-day trial an entire month all
you have to do is pay five bucks for the
shipping and handling you go to
curology.com off the record
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y dot com off the record
for a free 30-day trial only pay five
bucks for the shipping and handling of
the box and what's cool is you can
cancel at any time and your prescription
is subject to the consultation go check
them out oh that was my follow-up
question is did you meet someone that
you crushed on in person and then how
did that feel like and then robin
gibbons is one right yeah
not only crushed but you released on
that girl when i was young when i was
trying that's why yeah black girls black
girl yeah robin gibbons and robin
i mean
paul do you ever have a thing with
tatiana lee after filming no no you
didn't but we i mean because that was
all together we had some good goods i
knew we're like together i played her
boyfriend and fresh prince
robin gibbons on that episode too and
then
and then she played my girlfriend and
faking the [ __ ] but no i mean we also
partied in the same circle so i was
friends with her and her boyfriend at
the time jonathan brandis
oh seaquest
when it became real was it like did it
take the magic away and the crush away
nah she was still bad oh okay
did you try to smell her every now and
then
no she said she actually we we're in the
table re-right we're in the table read
well you guys are reading together so
before
before you shoot the show on monday you
should show on friday on monday the
whole cast gets together and they table
read and so you just do it like like
and so she's sitting next to me i'm like
damn and then she
she goes over to me because we're both
guest starring on the show and she's
like aren't you isn't it doesn't it make
you trip out like it feels like we're
like
you know like we're the guests on the
show everyone knows each other no like
we don't even know anybody and i'm like
talk i'm like yeah
like you're vibing with it like damn
we're both in this new experience
together in the back of my mind i'm like
damn i said
i remember you a playboy
very vividly
[Laughter]
hey worst movie you ever a part of worst
yeah oh that's a good question oh great
there's a movie that you can't find i
can't find it bet you all fine no no
i'll bet you you've finally
seen it i've never seen it it's called
sinbad in the dark knights or something
like that richard grieco played sinbad
richard grieco played sinbad yes
and i played his sidekick like the
prince of china i got like a turban i
got a sword and [ __ ]
we shot in jordan and like [ __ ]
i don't know bulgaria or something
and i mean dean stock was in the movies
people in the movie but it's like we're
running around i don't even [ __ ] know
i heard it's horrible i don't remember i
barely remember you didn't go to the
screening or nothing nah i got that
screen
you were the king of china bro i was a
prince of china my bad prince of china
kick on booker his side his his show the
spinoff i was a sidekick ping pong
that's called ping pong
your name was your name was ping pong oh
my god back in the day what year was
this this is [ __ ] 90
1990 races
can you guys call me ping-pong you look
like a ping pong can you guys go can i
just be pink
they call me pink he was like pink
that's so good you do look like a ping
pong okay
what's the most racist thing you've
experienced like on set other than being
named ping pong with a turban as prince
of china no no prince of china prince of
china is another one but then booker
while i was ping-pong
what's the most racist thing you've
experienced racist
being called people
be called ping-pong offset
now thinking back ping pong seemed real
racist in a way but it wasn't because i
wasn't playing a street kid oh cause i
was always if they hired me to play
asian role i was never the type of asian
right that anyone was one
so it was always like yeah he was john
usually i was like
not john johnstop jones doug jones but
like i wasn't like whatever i was like a
hip-hop asian kid so they're always like
oh you're like how do i make sense of
you is what they were doing
he goes you don't you don't look like a
guy that delivers chinese food to me so
i don't know what the [ __ ] to do to it
what are you well they didn't even know
what kind of asian i was they didn't
know what a filipino probably asked like
that what kind of asian are you always
they're like no they don't even like
they what are you they're like what is
your category and at the time a lot of
filipino actors were playing chinese
right you know not mexican
half my [ __ ] growing up was latino and
half of it was asian so i basically had
this thing i was like
what's the role
they're like
it's chinese and i go well
my grandma on my dad's side she's like
part chinese
or asian like oh yeah that makes sense
and then like i get the wrong
and they'd be like
damn it's just really like mexican i'm
like beautiful you know we're like
latino like we're we
we got colonized we're
like the latinos we grew up in paramount
oh you guys are like basically mexicans
like yeah the same same kind of stuff
and who's the most [ __ ] co-star you
have worked with
did you say that you can't be talking
about let me see
well you're in the hot seat everyone
knows what the hot seat is whatever you
say doesn't matter
all the time yeah
well i can't i can't change your name
yeah what does it rhyme with
[ __ ] okay uh how about this how is
this your how is this your
favorite co-star
my favorite without the winking without
the winking who's the favorite co-star
you never want to work with again i mean
i i know some some people like
you know the big stars are really cool
the big stars are
like
always they're always cool because
they're like they don't give a [ __ ]
they're like big stars
when smaller actors come in and they
just be doing too much like my steel
lines what's an example of something
they would do
slash their names full name no i don't
even remember their name and he's not a
bad person i don't know if i can so i
come to set one time he's like and we're
about to do the scene and this dude's
like going around doing [ __ ] i'm like
what are you doing he's like i just
don't know what animal i'm gonna be
today
that's the animal
my dude's like i come from a tiger
i'm like what the [ __ ] and then he's
like
what the [ __ ]
and i just got back from the philippines
and then we're trying to shoot this
scene he wants to tussle can we just
improv the fight scene like oh my god no
no we can't improv no [ __ ] fights
scene you're [ __ ] crazy
that doesn't even make sense in the
script
yelling at me [ __ ] wrong lines i'm like
this dude's [ __ ] while on the phone
he's a tiger today and he's on some
[ __ ] is he still an active actor
yeah i mean i guess it's just his style
maybe just wasn't it wasn't flowing with
my style at least not that day and i
definitely did not want to improv my
goddamn
toughness
when you when you were doing a hook did
anybody else screen test for rufio a
gang of people did a gang of people do
originally i heard i met another actor
that said he had got the role before i
did how many of them killed themselves
after they didn't get them
i don't know that's crazy so someone
else got the role before you and then
they they're like sorry dante's better
no supposedly but who knows kid actors
you know you're around the same circuit
people tell you stories all the time and
it's one of those kids one of the kids
that worked all the time he was like
robocop and he was
he was like oh you know i got that role
he's the bad kid yeah yeah ryan knows
everything he was um i know you're like
a cena i followed your career bro but
that kid
with that kid was like
i remember him i haven't seen him in
years but as kid actors he was kind of
strange like we were like young like 13
14 he would show like no shirt on like
with like a jacket like being crazy like
who is this kid and we're like 14 him
and his sister had like a weird he was
intense little dude
the thing about kid actors is we would
all
there's a one dentist office in in
in hollywood that we all go to how come
because he had specialized these things
called flippers where when you lose your
teeth you um they put fake teeth pop it
in for kids oh cause all kids be [ __ ]
losing teeth and then before invisalign
he had another thing they created that
was braces that you don't have to keep
in you can take your braces out so when
you're working you take one wow braces
yeah so we all like when you go there
you literally like every actor for the
last 40 years
is in that place so we all running to
each other at dr smith
i'm gonna ask you a real hot question
right now okay real hot one on some
serious on some serious [ __ ] you're a
kid actor
anybody in the industry ever like put
you in an uncomfortable situation or
take advantage of you like that
well you can't get through this industry
without like
an e true hollywood story you know what
i'm saying like especially i've been a
game 35 years and i started as a kid
thank god i haven't had the worst of it
but i've been around
darkness
and it was in the darkness
and
did the darkness touch you it didn't
touch me but it touched the family
member oh and it was
horrible it's not good damn
and it was um it's one of the things
that you go like
i almost wrote in my book but i'm like
it's not really my story to tell even
though it's very much affected by it but
it's like
real [ __ ] happens man do you go like is
this industry worth it because not only
does it that is like is
somewhere my fame and whatever i'm doing
did that help cause that oh [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying has has any
concept of justice come around for that
particular situation i mean
yeah i mean people i mean it's been
years ago so people people went to jail
people have
passed on now i mean it's very so there
was some form of justice like they
didn't come out and there is some form
of justice and as a kid going through it
you wish you could do more you just feel
so impotent
you know what i'm saying yeah and then
to family members you just you know you
there's times in life where you felt
like a man i wasn't there for you i
didn't do this right we didn't we could
have done like you know
but
as a family coming to hollywood
unequipped with what was gonna
happen with everything the fame and the
industry the ups the downs this
you know you know and then also being a
very an asian family so
it's already about saving face it's all
about
don't talk about
certain things and then all of a sudden
this becomes like
years of like oh [ __ ] don't talk about
that [ __ ] that happened you know what
i'm saying
shit's [ __ ] up but that's part of
that's part of the that's part of the
industry sometimes it's part of life but
it's just matter i'm glad you're still
standing up dude all right man yeah
thank you
[Music]
[Music]